a este equipo con una plantilla tan cara
es suficiente con el título de liga sin
duda no es suficiente pero hay un par de
puntos positivos lo primero es que
vivimos de vuelta al tridente el
tridente que ilusiona que evidentemente
desde el punto de vista tanto del
mercadeo como del fútbol tiene que
prometer digamos dentro del contexto no
solo de la liga francesa sino la europea
y también un neymar que aparece con gol
y me ha marcado seis goles en los
últimos tres encuentros eso es positivo
la hinchada empieza a animarse después
de la eliminación de la europa league de
la champions league pero no es
suficiente y si lo que se empieza a
plantear porque aparece además el nombre
de zinedine zidane de fondo pochetino
lohan no ha logrado encontrar ese
vínculo entre el proyecto deportivo que
espera además con unos recursos bastante
importantes de cara europa ya la liga de
francia no es suficiente y necesita
empezar a pensarse cómo encontrar esos
resultados que no se han dado a nivel
europeo creo que es el gran reto e iba a
ser difícil sostener además esta
plantilla una plantilla que si no
empieza a tener resultados sus figuras
van a querer buscar otros
otros rumbos ahora en plenas elecciones
en francia macrón incluso se animó a
decir que l iba a intentar ser un puente
para que embate se quede y sea el
símbolo de la juventud francesa en unos
momentos en los que además se esperan
los juegos olímpicos en parís entonces
son un montón digamos de factores más
allá de lo netamente futbolístico que
van a empezar a jugar pero sin duda yo
creo que al final de esta temporada
pochettino partirá caminos con el psg y
debe encontrarse de esa manera o ese
nuevo eje que empieza a liderar este
país a niermann a otro tipo de
resultados y un mba para que según los
rumores de la prensa precisamente
estaría viendo ahora con mejores ojos
quedarse en el pdc y no ir al real
madrid que una cosa que parecía que
estaba ya prácticamente hecho